[Música]
armas terroríficas que descienden del
cielo a velocidades Aparentemente
imposibles estos drones suicidas y
misiles de cruceros son disparados en
masa desde barcos y aviones rusos
Moscú ha estado enviando una lluvia de
destrucción sobre Ucrania durante dos
días lo que ha llevado al presidente
bolodimir selenski a pedir ayuda urgente
a los países del g7
les pido que refuercen Nuestro esfuerzo
conjunto para ayudar financieramente a
crear un escudo aéreo para Ucrania
Ucrania pretende instalar la llamada
cúpula de hierro similar a los sistemas
de defensa antimisiles que existen en
Israel o alrededor de Washington DC la
capital estadounidense está protegida
por el Sistema Nacional avanzado de
misiles tierra aire para Ucrania esta
tecnología podría ser un escudo crucial
en 10 segundos el sistema puede detectar
misiles enemigos y destruirlos en pleno
vuelo creando en efecto una burbuja de
protección
el sistema nasams tiene una capacidad de
interceptación de hasta 150 kilómetros
el uso principal de este sistema Sería
para la defensa de kiev y la defensa de
las principales ciudades en concreto
actualmente no podemos hacer una burbuja
100% impenetrable incluso con muchos
sistemas combinados de múltiples capas
en un solo lugar según el Ministerio de
defensa de Ucrania la mitad de los 84
misiles de crucero rusos fueron
interceptados el lunes como aquí
de un soldado ucraniano utilizó un misil
disparado desde el hombro con gran
efecto para su defensa antiaérea kiev
despliega actualmente pequeños
lanzadores de misiles portátiles y
sistemas s-300 desarrollados por la
antigua Unión soviética El martes llegó
desde Alemania el primer sistema de
defensa antiaérea Iris más sofisticado
mientras Estados Unidos ha aprobado el
envío de al menos 8 baterías de sus
afamados nasams a Ucrania